hallo mein name ist luca und ich spiele
heute das spiel jonas oder jura nass
oder jura und dieses spiel ist ein spiel
von youtube für leute die youtube
schauen jetzt sind wir auch schon nicht
lukrativ wir klicken einfach mal noch
gleich hab bisher noch nicht gespielt
deppe um zu springen das heißt die so
springe ich werbung wird geladen was ok
ich muss hier irgendwie wie soll ich
denn da langstadt ii muss darunter
bleiben dass ich da irgendwie werte
guckt ach ich kann es leider auch gerade
hier alles klar
man kommt da nicht drüber
ich komm hier ach ich kann auf die
draufsteht dass ich alles erledigt so
machen wir noch schönen dingen hier ist
leiden wir drunter ließ ist fakt ist es
sind einige youtuber in dem spiel frau
darum mehr geld ich als youtuber muss
natürlich das geld direkt einmal mehr
als ein blöder high school kommen hier
drauf so hier drunter herzleiden hier
wieder drauf hier ihn um jumpen hier
drauf das schön das geld mitnehmen hier
weiter laufen hier auf ihn drauf
springen wir ab auf den kühlschrank
wieder das geld mitnehmen
hier kommt auch wieder das und diese
steht man dann immer dass ich null views
habe was soll das denn ich kann mich
nicht mit twitter verbinde ich bin im
flugzeugmodus weil ich voll wenig akku
habe komme dieses spiel gibt mir denn
ich habe keine kamera eingesammelt ich
hab noch eine kamera eingesammelt jetzt
ja warschau 770 views nein das wird nun
kameras berechnet
so direkt wieder tot kamera
die ganze scheiße funktioniert sei ich
spring ich hier über ihnen darüber dann
geb ich mir natürlich direkt den
nächsten springen bei ihnen rüber dann
hier drauf da oben die kamera ist
natürlich mitnehmen können sich jetzt
aber vergessen hier die kamera ich habe
auf slide gedrückt dubach ich kann mir
new look aus dem ok ich bin bereit mit
den heißen 12 die boy-group das ist der
fortschritt tv oder wir haben baby wir
haben ein paar liebe haben revier haben
easy und das war's und ich habe kein
geld oder habe ich geld nicht ob
überhaupt keine idee was das denn ich
habe neue zimmer kaufen wenn macht das
jc wiesbaden
ich will nicht kaufen jumpen wir halt
noch ein bisschen rum und holen zum paar
kameras eventuell was was bringen mir
den kameras außer hughes kann ich nicht
rein theorie ich bin darüber gesprochen
ich bin darüber gesprochen boos und die
anderen nichts gegen euch aber die app
ist stark verbesserungswürdig also dass
hier so eine werbung geladen wird das
einfach hier
ich weiß nicht ich springe darüber und
es funktioniert trotzdem nicht und mir
kommt es so vor als wäre alles noch ich
brauche doch nur die kamera habe du
blöder do.com zuvor als wenn alles nur
darauf basiert den leuten hier bei
twitter zu folgen oder geld zu bezahlen
und das loch und jetzt lebt
wahrscheinlich wieder auch eine werbung
das spiel ist nicht so mein ding aber
wir können ja mal schauen ob wir hier
noch ein bisschen was reißen können ich
möchte auch eigentlich mal ganz gerne
die 20 kameras da oben einsammeln weil
ich überhaupt nicht weiß was dann
passiert zudem ist die steuerung auch
einfach mega schwammig also ich drück
jetzt beispielsweise einmal ganz kurz
und er springt richtig hoch weil ich
dann mal wieder kurz drücke dann gibt es
das auch schon wieder ich keine ahnung
ich find das spiel derzeit ein bisschen
komisch
5600 views what's going on
und natürlich liegt die werbung schon
wieder übrigens falls euch fragt wieso
ich rote auge habe ich bin einfach ich
bin tot ich bin mega krank eventuell hat
man es auch dass sich nur durch die nase
rede also es tut mir leid dass die
dieses video und eventuell auch die
nächsten videos so ein bisschen
angeschlagen aufgenommen werden
auch man es ist doch nicht war ein
scheiß unterlegt schon wieder die
werbung einer liebe freunde ich weiß
nicht ich finde das spiel nicht so toll
respekt dass sie so etwas geschafft habt
und im spiel entwickelt habt alle es ist
für mich wirklich nur komplett auf
werbung und geld basiert und ihr könnt
selbst im app store gehen und euch das
downloaden das heißt jura nass und es
selbst mal testen denn euch das video
trotzdem gefallen habe ich mich immer
eine bewertung von wir sehen uns morgen
wieder zu